such as well and as you mentioned you  are in talks and we we had a tweet by  Taria today mentioning that the  Norwegian vice president uh from fide is  following the situation around Carlson  and expecting a statement from fide uh  in the coming days so can we expect an  official statement from Freedia  regarding uh the chaos definitely  definitely I think it should come maybe  in a few days time uh what's important  to understand and many people do not  realize it players are great  private platforms are awesome but at the  end of the day if you talk about entity  who can shoot and who has the duty to to  protect at all it's only feeder because  of at the end of the day players care  about themselves and that's normal  platforms private platforms they're  caring in midterm or long term about  their income about that that Fida is the  only body which is known for profit body  which is main primary goal is to develop  chess to protect